Hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to have missed
d23 but we've been working very hard on the next
Deadpool film for uh a good long while now I've
had to really search my soul on this one uh his
first appearance in the MCU obviously needs to
feel special we need to stay true to the character
uh finding new depth and motivation new meaning
every Deadpool needs to stand out and stand apart
it's been an incredible challenge that has forced
me to reach down deep inside and I have nothing
yeah just completely empty up here and
terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play
Wolverine one more time yeah sure
Welcome Back everyone, maximum effort. This will be my Deadpool 3 teaserfor Wolverine coming back
this is huge news they
just confirmed Hugh Jackman returning as Wolverine
in like a Deadpool vs Wolverine or Deadpool and
Wolverine probably not them fighting each other
maybe a little bit of fighting each other but
probably more of a team-up movie Wild shock I'll
explain what's going on with this because the
really cool thing is that Ryan Reynolds said that
before the big Disney buyout they were actually
planning for Deadpool 3 to beat a Deadpool
Wolverine movie with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
if you're brand new to the channel I'll be doing
videos for the movie just like I do for all the
other Deadpool films so be sure to subscribe to
get them the teaser he released here obviously
just meant to be very tongue-in-cheek like oh you
know we meant to make this big announcement at d23
but sorry we missed it I think the reason why they
waited on that is because they were one waiting
for the ink to dry on some of the contracts like
actually just working through the deal to get Hugh
Jackman back and they were already making a bunch
of really huge announcements even though it would
have been cool to find out about this during the
big d23 panel I've already done a separate video
about all the really big stuff that they announced
in some of the teasers so I'll link those at the
end of this and down in the description too
love the way that he's actually talking about
working him into the MCU while he's wearing the
costume from Deadpool 2. like the very ashy torn
up looking costume I think one of the reasons for
doing that is to let you know that it is going to
be the same Deadpool from the fox X-Men Universe
like it'll be more of a Multiverse character
or my idea actually early on it was kind of a
funny idea was that they would just say that
he'd been in the MCU this whole time and wouldn't
really address it in a big way like that'd be one
of the big jokes of the movies he's been in the
MCU the whole time and nobody noticed until now
you noticed during this there are a couple little
Easter eggs for a lot of his other businesses that
he has in real life separate from his acting like
he's wearing the wrexham Hat he pours himself some
Aviation gin which is his gin brand he's got his
Deadpool mug it does seem weird to be drinking gin
out of a Deadpool mug a little while with him on
the can wearing the Deadpool costume if he can't
tell zoom and enhanced that's a Marvel comic book
that he's reading on the can so it's all part of
the joke that he's trying to look for ideas for
the actual movie but the bigger joke here is that
he says he's been spending all this time trying to
figure out what to do with the movie but he can't
think of anything he's like I have nothing I can't
figure it out so the joke is is that they went to
get Hugh Jackman to come back because he couldn't
think of a decent movie without Hugh Jackman
yeah completely empty up here and
terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one more
time yeah sure I also love the idea that he's
either hanging out in Hugh Jackman's house
like he's broken into Hugh Jackman's house
or he and Hugh Jackman just went off into the
woods to stay together for a while when he said
that Ryan Reynolds was like do you want to play
Wolverine one more time I don't know what that
means literally just one more time because I think
we were expecting Hugh Jackman to finally come
back as Wolverine in the MCU during Avengers six
Secret Wars just because all the Multiverse stuff
happening in that movie I think the difference
with Deadpool 3 is that he'll be like a really
big part of the movie and during Avengers 6 Secret
Wars he might just be like a small part of that
movie like a cameo level part of that movie they
explained that some of the Marvel contracts with
actors work a little bit different like when
you hear about the actors signing six picture
contracts with Marvel they actually differentiate
what kind of appearance it is based on how long
they're in the film and if they're not in the film
for a long enough duration it doesn't actually
count against one of their options so like I said
Deadpool 3 meant to be a lot of Wolverine in the
entire movie it's not just like him showing up
at the end in some sort of joke and when they
reveal the release date is September 6 2020 24 in
a couple years they used the Whitney Houston song
but as I will always love Hugh and they actually
put him in the title but the funny thing about
the logo here like they have Wolverine's claws
through the Deadpool symbol those were actually
a lot of the fan logos that people were releasing
the last couple of years when we were crying for
them to bring Wolverine back in the MCU after all
this Deadpool news happened one of the other big
things that's happening during this phase is
that they are going to have a lot more mutants
a lot more X-Men characters running around
in the MCU by the time the film comes out so
there'll probably be a lot of those characters
in this movie like there'll be a lot of X-Men
mutant characters because Deadpool Wolverine both
mutants X-Men like literally X-Men inside the MCU
because Hugh Jackman of course but this is still
meant to be way before they release their next
full-blown X-Men reboot movie because of him
coming back in the MCU I also kind of wonder
what this means about them doing a version of
Wolverine with a different actor like that they
always wanted to be the Hugh Jackman version of
Wolverine or will they follow up on Logan and
pass the torch to x-23 because there's the whole
timeline question there that's a Deadpool joke in
and of itself these timelines are so confusing we
just got Miss Marvel canonized as a mutant in the
MCU they use the X-Men animated series theme song
during her episode when they revealed it and they
also confirmed that Namor is going to be a mutant
in the MCU during black panther wakanda forever so
they're like the tip of the iceberg even though
technically Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver in her
children Billy and Tommy are kind of mutants
already I did a video about Deadpool coming to
the MC a while ago because during Doctor Strange
2 Multiverse of Madness they had all those X-Men
Cameo scenes the writer of Doctor Strange 2 also
said that he was going to have a post-credits
scene with Deadpool at one point it would have
been like the funny second post-credits scene
instead of that Bruce Campbell post-credit scene
with him breaking the fourth ball kind of like
Deadpool looking at his hand joking about the Evil
Dead movie series because those are also Sam Raimi
movies there have been a lot of jokes about
how they were going to bring Deadpool into the
MCU how they would address it like wouldn't it be
funny if Deadpool just showed up in the MCU during
Deadpool 3 as if he'd been here the whole time in
the MCU is it gonna have something to do with the
incursions The Secret Wars teaser and the Doctor
Strange 2 post credit scene the writers were just
saying that they actually had to work all those
details out before they actually wrote Deadpool
3. a long time ago Kevin feige actually wanted to
bring Wolverine in a cameo scene during the first
Captain America movie he was going to have a Hugh
Jackman Cameo as the Wolverine character but the
whole idea is that he hasn't become Wolverine
yet like he doesn't have the adamantium till
much later in the timeline and it's because the
character was actually born in the 1800s so he
lived through all these different Wars this whole
time before he joined the weapon x program at the
beginning of Wolverine Origins you see one of
the wars he's fighting in is World War II his
big Cameo scene during the first Captain America
movie was going to be in the scene where he goes
to rescue all the pows in the Howling Commandos
Hugh Jackman's Logan was going to be one of the
characters that he rescued I've talked about this
in the past but they've already laid a lot of the
groundwork for introducing Weapon X into the MCU
like they have a version of weapons plus already
Weapon X is part of that or a bit of a spin-off
of that the other cool thing here for those of
you that want a Hulk versus Wolverine movie in
the MCU I don't know if they're ever actually
going to do that but it sounds like there's a lot
of world war Hulk stuff happening between captain
America 4 in the Thunderbolts movie like there's
a lot of Hulk related plot those movies would be
a really good time to introduce a concept of MCU
Weapon X because both Captain America 4 and the
Thunderbolts movie will be coming out right after
Daredevil the cool thing is it'll also probably
cross over a little bit with the Daredevil Born
Again episodes depending on when that premieres
so 2024 is going to be a banger year for Marvel
movies in Disney plus series and they actually
reveal this completely separate plot for a totally
different Deadpool 3 movie that they would have
made had the deal not gone through in Marvel not
gotten the Deadpool character back they said that
when they were going to do Deadpool 3 at Fox and
it was just going to be its own little Solo movie
they were actually going to do a road trip as
a Deadpool and Wolverine crossover movie that's
right everybody wondering if they were ever
going to do a Deadpool Wolverine team up with
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine it was actually going
to happen during that Deadpool 3 movie and even
though the Logan movie came out right around that
time and killed off the Wolverine Logan character
later in the timeline also the Patrick Stewart
Professor X character from those original X-Men
movies from that same line of cotton annuity but
everyone posts all your theories in the comments
below what do you want them to do with Wolverine
as a character just as a concept in the MCU after
the Deadpool 3 Wolverine movie if it really does
wind up being Hugh Jackman's last actual film
their only option after that would be to use them
in like one-off cameos or to completely recast a
version of the character which means that the
Deadpool 3 version of Wolverine would have to
be the Multiverse version like the version from
the fox X-Men Universe they already canonized
the fox X-Men movies as being in the same universe
as the fox Deadpool movie like they have that big
crossover scene to let you know oh this is all
happening in the same Earth so at least for now
I'm assuming that the version that Hugh Jackman
plays in Deadpool 3 will be the same version of
Wolverine we've been watching this whole time
just a little bit earlier in this timeline you
have to remember the events of Logan took place
in a distant future so like we haven't actually
gotten to the period where that takes place so
that means that there are all these Adventures
that they could have with them before that and
that's how you bring him back without having to
completely undo the events of Logan I'll do
a bunch more videos about it as we get more
news and more teasers I'm sure Ryan Reynolds
will be dropping more funny videos like this
just hinting at what's going on the actual plot
with any luck we'll get Hugh Jackman inside that
yellow Wolverine costume there's a bunch of big
stuff coming up be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss anything everyone click
here for my house the Dragon episode 7 video and
click here for my new secret Invasion trailer
video and all those d23 announcements about
all the big Marvel movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!